ja liebe zuschauer herzlich willkommen
beim bild buschung hier erfahren sie
jeden tag was hinter den kulissen des
dschungelcamps passiert und mit mir
heute hier im bild busch sozusagen die
dschungelkönigin aus dem jahr 2004
désirée nick kandidaten sie sind bereits
eingezogen in das camp und wir hier bei
bild haben die ersten exklusiven bilder
die wollen wir ihnen jetzt zeigen denn
es gab schon eine erste prüfung und
diese prüfung war in
schwindelerregender höhe ein bälle
parcours
40 meter über dem boden ja aber eine
kandidatin die fehlte bei dieser prüfung
und zwar geht es um christina
war für sie war das dschungelcamp ganz
ganz schnell wieder vorbei bevor es
überhaupt losging denn rtl hat sie
rausgeschmissen weil es unstimmigkeiten
in bezug auf ihren impfpass gab ja und
sie musste die koffer bereits packen aus
die maus ab nach haus und unsere
reporterin killer ortmann hat sie
exklusiv am flughafen in südafrika
getroffen und ich kann ihnen sagen die
reaktion über nicht besonders nett
[Musik]
ich möchte es nicht in ordnung dass
damit ein schlimmes passiert ist
deswegen will persönlichkeitsrecht
gefährdung und habe keine interviews und
ich habe die
rechtsanwälte zeitung ist doch was
passiert ist nämlich nicht passieren es
gibt keine lego und das was gerade
abgeht in der presse ohne belegt und
sonstiges
deswegen bin ich ganz ruhig mal
höchstens aufklären
ok wird den mutter
nawal kandidatin christine macht ihrem
namen wirklich alle ehre
wir wollen jetzt aber noch mal mit der
frau sprechen die sie am flughafen
getroffen hat ihre ortmann unsere junge
reporterin ist seit über einer woche in
südafrika sie ist unser auge sie ist
unser ohr in den busch und sie rufen wir
jetzt an mit unserem dschungeltelefon
kannst du mich hören
ich kann mich super höheren guten morgen
wunderbar wir müssen eine sache vorweg
sagen christian opfer hat gerade gesagt
wir würden die unwahrheit sagen dazu
muss man natürlich einmal sagen wir
haben das berichtet was rtl auch gesagt
habe hat es gab unstimmigkeiten
bezüglich ihres im status zudem haben
wir mit mehreren quellen gesprochen die
gesagt haben dass sie wohl sehr wenig
antikörper hatte und dass alles darauf
hinweist dass sie nicht geimpft sei
wie erklärst du dir jetzt ihre doch sehr
harsche reaktionen dir gegenüber
wer tatsächlich gestern wirklich sofort
von anfang an sehr aggressiv gewirkt und
sehr er sich aggressiv verhalten
wir haben uns als wir sie am flughafen
hier in holzbrett in südafrika getroffen
haben erst einmal vorgestellt sind ganz
ruhig auf sie zugegangen und wollten
erst mal nur sagen hallo wir sind auch
hier und da hat sie direkt uns angezeigt
das flughafenpersonal angezeigt weil sie
versucht sich jetzt natürlich mit ihrer
aggressiven art so ein bisschen zu
verteidigen denn sie weiß ganz genau da
ist etwas falsch gelaufen und sie hat ja
tatsächlich bisher auch noch nicht
geäußert und dazu wollten wir gestern
die chance geben weil sie sagt jetzt ist
sind unwahrheiten irgendwie stehen im
raum aber sie könnte sie ja einfach
aufklären deswegen waren wir da das ist
letztendlich auch unser job da danach zu
fragen wenn sie sagt wir behaupten
unwahrheiten dann soll sie es doch bitte
rechtfertigen und davor auf hatte sie
tatsächlich auch keine antwort hat sich
eben mit dieser aggressivität so quasi
verteidigt und tatsächlich ist auch ihre
sehr voluminöse art anderen fluggästen
gestern da am flughafen unangenehm
aufgefallen eine frau sagte zu mir nein
ich hoffe ich sitze mit der gleich nicht
im flieger und auch ihre begleitperson
andres der mit ihr zurück geflogen ist
der hat auch nur beschämt zurück gekauft
und wollte sich dann auch nicht äußern
kira sie ist mittlerweile in deutschland
angekommen das haben wir heute morgen
erfahren aber es drohen ihr auch noch
konsequenzen hierzulande richtig
tatsächlich hat uns ein sprecher der
bundespolizei heute morgen bestätigt
dass christina paare in frankfurt
angekommen ist und tatsächlich auch
direkt von in verhört werde ich wurde
eben aufgrund dieser gerüchte dass sie
ihren impfpass gefälscht hätte sie
weitere informationen konnten sie uns
natürlich aus ermittlungstaktischen
gründen aktuell nicht liefern denn die
ermittlungen laufen noch auf das wurde
uns bestätigt ja und christin wollte
sich dazu komplett gar nicht mehr äußern
sie hat jetzt auch bei instagram noch
einmal gesagt ich sage nichts und wieder
von diesen unwahrheiten gesprochen aber
da werden wir natürlich noch weiter
genau hinhören auch mit der
bundespolizei stehen wir natürlich in
kontakt und werden darüber berichten und
sie soll auch ihre fans belogen haben
was war da los
ja ganz genau kurz vor dem abflug hat
sie noch eine instagram story gepostet
und hat darin geschrieben hallo ich will
heute die wende noch eine kleine safari
machen oder vielleicht auch ein mikro
flug und da war sie aber tatsächlich in
wahrheit eben schon auf dem weg zum
flughafen das hat mich einfach sehr
gewundert denn wir wussten wann sie ab
fliegt und als ich die dienste sorry
gesehen da war habe ich direkt gedacht
hey warum lügt sie denn jetzt ihre fans
an die da weiß doch dass sie nicht mehr
im dschungelcamp teilnimmt dann könnte
sie doch auch so ehrlich sein und dann
eben sagen ja jetzt ist der zeitpunkt
gekommen an dem ich auch südafrika
verlassen sie hat jetzt gerade eben
wenigen minuten über instagram gesagt
dass sie die presseleute verunsichern
wollte damit sie eben nicht abgefangen
wird am flughafen aber das ist natürlich
eventuell jetzt auch einfach nur eine
rechtfertigung im nachhinein weil ihr
plan letztendlich dann doch aufgeflogen
ist
danke dir kira gehetzt uns natürlich
über alles was dort passiert auf dem
laufenden danke dir
diese idee wir gehen
ja die wichtigste frage so christin
einmal ist es gut dass sie raus ist für
sie kommt ja jetzt jasmin herein oder
handy krawall nudel gerne noch im camp
gesehen also ich muss sagen sie hat es
ja wirklich geschafft mehr schlagzeilen
zu produzieren als manche der zwölf
insassen es am ende getan haben werden
da sind ja auch ein paar schauspieler
dabei die brauchen ja immer text um zu
erfahren dass es für schauspieler nicht
so leichtes terror ohne textbuch ohne
rollen nur man selbst zu sein und
ich hätte sie gerne erlebt weil sie ist
konfliktfähig und wir wollen kein
kuschel camp und kein ponyhof und ich
hätte sie wirklich sehr gerne in dialog
auf augenhöhe mit anderen insassinnen
erlebt mir tut es ein bisschen leid aber
was ich nie verstanden habe ist wie so
einige as miel herren überhaupt auf der
ersatzbank sitzt denn sie ist voll von
geschichten sie kann anknüpfen auch an
meine zeit mit willi herren den ich ja
nicht besonders sympathisch oder
harmonie bedürftig damals im
dschungelcamp erlebt habe wir hatten
große konflikte und die hat sehr viele
anknüpfungspunkte weil sie auch immer
geschwiegen hat zu den tatsächlichen
ereignissen mit der familie herren die
ihr ja wohl nach dem leben trachten und
ich glaube nach allem was man über diese
familie so hört über den konflikt auch
mit frau herren ist ja jetzt für sie der
sicherste ort der weg in südafrika dann
kann sie nicht umgelegt werden da kann
sie nicht ermordet werden man trachtet
ihr weil ja wohl nach dem legen also ich
glaube sie wird eine grandiose zeit
haben weil sie in sicherheit das sind 1
wenn man mal sagen man ist natürlich bei
einem solchen projekt sicher als in
seinem ganzen leben zuvor oder danach
denn man ist umgeben von 300 menschen
die auf einen aufpassen vorliegt wir
wollen noch einmal ganz gucken wer denn
jetzt tatsächlich ins camp einzieht denn
wir wissen auf lukas cordalis kann mich
einzigen ballack ohne positiv ist also
es gab ein riesen kurs großes chaos im
vorfeld liebe zuschauer hier sehen sie
noch einmal wer jetzt wirklich dabei ist
es ist die mutter aller trash tv formate
das dschungelcamp ein
zusammengewürfelter haufen von 11
möchtegern promis die irgendwann mal
durch die flimmerkiste gerutscht sind
und hier die kandidaten das sprechen der
ersatzteillager mit mehr silikon im
gesicht als in den regalen eines
baumarktes
modedesigner harald glööckler
er hat dem elend schon einmal die stirn
geboten nämlich als ehemaliger kandidat
bei der bachelor red da hat er sein
wirken reflex bereits ausreichend
trainiert philipp pablo mit nach dem
fuchsschwanz an til schweigers manta der
zerhackte känguru penis auf dem teller
guten appetit wünschen wir
schauspielerin tina ruland
manuel flickinger in der ersten staffel
von prinz charming hat er leider
vergeblich nach der großen liebe gesucht
boiler im dschungel wird wie ihn auch
nur das lagerfeuer klettern was folgt
auch der karriereleiter nachdem man
bereits promi big brother durchgespielt
hat das dschungelcamp
glückwunsch an schauspielerin anouschka
renzi mit dem namen hätte er mal besser
pornodarsteller werden sollen eric steht
fest von gzsz über letztens rein ins
dickicht viel spaß dabei anfang des
jahres kämpft sie noch um bachelor nico
die letzte kurve kriegt sie nicht dafür
wartet jetzt im dschungelcamp ein ganzer
urwald ein grünzeug aussieht lindenberg
er hatte sie alle peter althof hat sich
als bodyguard legende einen namen
gemacht und geschützt die reichen und
schönen dieser welt ob er auch seine
mitkämpfer beschützen kann bleibt
abzuwarten
und wie hier ist auch dabei und tabitha
[Musik]
ja die österreicherin liebt reality
shows und steht zu ihrem motto mehr ist
mehr sieht man ja
wie ihr testet vor über 20 jahren pop
titan dieter bohlen in einer hamburger
boutique mit angrenzendem teppichladen
die auslegeware auf stoßfestigkeit auf
dem roten teppich nach südafrika janina
jost pia reality shows sind ihr zweites
zuhause jasmin herren direkt von willi
herren will als nachrückerin die
dschungel krone holen ja die miete muss
halt irgendwie verdient werden macht ein
positiver test jetzt alles kaputt super
skoda ließ ehemann von daniela
katzenberger und sohn vom allerersten
dschungelkönig steht kurz vorm dschungel
aus ob er nachrücken kann steht noch
nicht fest zwei wochen urlaub von
daniela katzenberger würden wir ihm
jedenfalls doch sehr gönnen
11freunde oder elf feinde über diese
frage müssen wir jetzt einmal sprechen
desiree nick hier bei unseren wedbush
honeck größtes zecken potenzial zwischen
wem wird krachen also ich habe ja jasmin
al awsat jan dass teppiche oder
kennengelernt wir haben eine woche
zusammen jeden tag verbracht denn wir
haben gemeinsam shopping queen gedreht
und ich kann nur sagen die es sofort
dass sogar das plumpsklo im busch
neidisch werden wird sie hat nämlich uns
alle immerhin gestandene profis in die
wohnung ihres schönheits chirurgen
lanciert und hat uns vorgelogen sie
würde dort leben natürlich hat man das
gemerkt das war eine meiner wohnung und
ich gehe ja immer ins taxi die
schubladen auf also da hatten kerl
gewohnt es stellte sich dann heraus es
war ihr schönheitschirurg und sie
glaubte wirklich dass sie einen ganzen
team natürlich auch mit redaktion vorzug
man kann ja ich lebe ich es meine
wohnung weil da ein paar rote rosen in
ein paar vasen also auch nicht also
passt nicht so mit der ehrlichkeit so
und jetzt kommen wir aber zu deiner
ihrer frage und sie hat jetzt aber
anfang 30 natürlich harte konkurrenz von
diesen nachwuchs aus dem sogenannten
dating formaten um nicht zu sagen bums
formaten die beiden anderen lässt die
bestimmt ihr konzept nämlich dating show
wir reden von terra.vita genau und die
anderen vier zylindern uhr war genau die
beiden werden natürlich ihr projekt auch
durch das sie in die öffentlichkeit
gekommen sind dating show in den
dschungel übertragen also sowas wie die
schachtel in der schachtel die puppe in
der puppe die haben ja wohl auch schon
dem filipovic im visier und die sind
aber nun jung und ob eine jasmina durch
seit jahren sich damit abfinden kann
dass sie auf die mitte 30 zugeht und die
jüngere konkurrenz hat er auch den rang
als sexbombe streitig macht ich glaube
da steckt immer
gesagt typen potenzial erkennt potenzial
drin aber auch tippen potenzierten
potenzial gibt in der arena auf jeden
fall ich weiß gar nicht ob echte brüste
überhaupt ins dschungelcamp 1 sie hat ja
nichtmal harald glööckler der hat ja
auch falschen brüste man kann ja heute
auch falsche sixpack haben und falschen
hintern machen auch gerne die männer
absolut brasilien bad wird sie genannt
hüllen auflage sie haben es gerade schon
gesagt ist dating format also knistern
am lagerfeuer gehört der irgendwie auch
dazu herr pavlovic es auf der suche nach
einer frau tara ist auf der suche nach
dem richtigen mann ebenfalls könnten wir
da gegebenenfalls das erste mal so ein
bisschen sex im camp moment es gab ja
kim gloss mit dem ochsenknecht spross
die haben ja ein kind bekommen aber
danach das war aber auch für ungefähr
ich glaube zehn jahren also die welt
entwickelt entwickelt sich weiter und
ich glaube dass sie schon gas geben
werden also es sind ja leute die sind in
die öffentlichkeit gekommen durch
datingshow sie waren zu allem bereit und
sie waren auch bereit zu kämpfen und es
geht ja um was und ich denke die werden
gas geben ich wünsche es der redaktion
denn nur harmonie bilder am lagerfeuer
die langweilen und wenn die uns
vielleicht so ein bisschen soft power
bieten ich glaube das sind bilder die
werden großen marktwert haben und leider
ist es ja heute so dass es format nicht
merkur ist das heißt die teilnehmer
haben analysiert verglichen sie wissen
wie kriege ich sendezeit sie waren schon
in anderen formaten also sie sind nicht
unbeleckt und ich denke das hat
potenzial
worauf sich die zuschauer immer am
meisten freuen sind ja die prüfungen sie
mussten auch einiges über sich ergehen
lassen es ist dann ist immer ganz so ja
ja sag ich mal lecker sondern auch
manchmal ganz schön eklig und unsere
kollegin kyra ortmann hat mal die
kulinarischen köstlichkeiten in
südafrika getestet
bevor es bei den promis losgehen wollen
wir schon mal ausprobieren was es hier
in südafrika eigentlich soviel
spezialitäten gibt und ich sitze jetzt
hier mit anzahl jan-dirk und nicolas und
die drei helfen wir jetzt das richtige
zum mittagessen zu finden
uns hier ja dirk und nicolas sind in
südafrika aufgewachsen wir gehen zuerst
auf die suche nach grashüpfern davon
soll es in südafrika etliche geben aber
die sind gar nicht so einfach zu fangen
[Musik]
di grassi verrichten hier für die
landwirtschaft einen enormen schaden an
also ist es sogar gut sie zu essen denn
sie ruinieren die pflanzen was du jemals
einen gegessen ja als ich noch klein war
normalerweise macht man das nur wenn man
so vier jahre alt ist du besuchst damit
also unsere kindheit
und dann wird's erst
drückte seinen kopf runter ich fühle
mich so schlecht für ihn
finde er sieht so schön aus aber es gibt
viele von ihnen keine sorge
nämlich vielleicht hättest du das
mikrofon test
und jetzt soll ich den so essen
ich will nicht dass er noch mehr leiden
muss ich stecke ihn also einfach in
meinem und ihr ein bisschen drüber nach
machst
hast du ihn runtergeschluckt
du bist jetzt eines stolze
südafrikanerin
also man denkt ja immer dass an so einem
kleinen insekten nichts dran ist aber
als ich da drauf gebissen habe kam da
ebenso die in der reinheit raus und das
war so eklig so würde ich das wirklich
niemandem empfehlen und ich kann gerade
die promis so was von verstehen dass die
einfachen sich von diesen prüfungen so
eklig das kommt wohl als nächstes
wie schon der name insekt wir haben noch
einen weg gefunden das du probieren
kannst es ist nicht das appetitliche
aber es ist tatsächlich in manchen
afrikanischen ländern eine delikatesse
in south africa and kann schließt eine
kakerlake meine absoluten hass insekten
wir würden die raten den kopf zu nehmen
und ihnen hinten in den mund zu stecken
dann weißt du einfach west zu damit es
nicht in deinem und krabbelt oder
versucht zu klettern
[Musik]
ich pack das nicht dass sie dass sie
lebt und ich werde das essen aber nicht
lebendig okay jetzt
bewegt er sich nicht mehr da musst du
dir keine sorgen machen now it's like
jetzt ist es einfach wie ein dicker
chips
war gut gemacht gut hingerichtet
also tatsächlich war der geschmack jetzt
gar nicht so schlecht aber diese
vorstellung diese kakerlake mit diesen
ganzen füßen und ohr macht es nicht
[Musik]
wir haben jetzt mal kurz unsere location
gewechselt sind jetzt bei simeon zu
hause und suchen nach ehrt fürmann und
[Musik]
würmer sollen besonders gut angebraten
stecken mit olivenöl und knoblauch
dieser liegt wie man sieht ist dort viel
knoblauch an den würmern am besten
schreibst du den erst ab sonst schmeckst
du nur den knoblauch
ich glaube da darf man auch einfach
nicht hingucken wenn man künftig
[Gelächter]
drei südafrikanische insekten gegessen
dschungel prüfung bestanden
ja gut dass ich noch nicht gefrühstückt
habe aber für sie frau nick ist das
wahrscheinlich was die kollegin deine
matten klacks weil sie haben ja ziemlich
widerlich dinge damals im dschungel
essen müssen ja naja bei kentucky fried
chicken soll ja auch immer mein schnabel
dabei seien nicht also das ist schon
wahr aber man soll nicht so viel drüber
nachdenken ich hatte ja den berühmten
känguru-hoden nadal schlug es runter und
den musste ich allerdings mit einer
gabel aus dieser ist aus dieser
verhüllung des hohlen herausdrücken und
das wusste ich anfangs nicht ich habe
mein amt am anfang wirklich versucht mit
den widerhaken eines haarigen bodens des
runterzuschlucken und jammer ich dann so
froh weil das wäre mir echt nicht
gelungen dass es einfach glitschig ist
dass es dann auch ganz schnell gehen
also dann nehme ich ja lieber die
heuschrecke kakerlake finde ich ziemlich
widerlich ehrlicher weise den gedanken
wir gucken aber nochmal auf den
aktuellen dschungel auf die teilnehmer
ja wer ist ihr persönlicher favorit und
vor einigen wer hat das meiste
unterhaltungspotenzial weil es ist eine
unterhaltungsshow und wir alle wollen es
sehen den krieg unter den kandidaten den
bescheid
also frau rennt sie hat ja angekündigt
dass sie dieses mal humor zeigen will
das ist natürlich schwierig wenn man die
polizei ruft wenn man einen witz nicht
versteht was er ja gerne mal macht
insbesondere bei mir und ich bin aber
froh dass der zickenkrieg nicht nur
frühstück zwischen den frauen
stattfindet dass es auch länder
technische sachen die man hinterfragen
sollte also was ist denn die männliche
form von zicken denn wir haben ja hallo
plan und betrieb und den flickinger
humor ist ja die gleitcreme des lebens
nun ist ja der manuell flickinger
hervorgegangen aus prinz charming längst
nicht so medien erfahren wie herr
glööckler in spanien für alle die es
nicht wissen ist dass condor sozusagen
wechsel nur mit männern für die lgbt
community und da ist herr flickinger ja
weit gekommen und ich glaube nicht dass
harald glöckler damit gerechnet hat dass
aus dieser community konkurrenz
auftreten wird und da kann man sich auf
so manchen bock alias zickenkrieg
sicherlich freuen aber ich möchte den
jungs einen tipp geben nie ein
versprechen geben was dein arsch nicht
halten kann humor ist die gleitcreme des
lebens ich sage es noch mal und ich
hoffe beide haben gleitcreme dabei also
ich denke da ist etwas drin was wir
bislang noch nicht gesehen haben denn
meistens wurde wie beispielsweise auch
ein matthias mann japaner immer so als
kleine eine frohnatur aus der community
mitgenommen aber dass wir dann auch
einen gegenspieler haben und die sind
sie sich ja auch nicht immer ganz grün
innerhalb dieser community das wäre doch
mal was neues also désirée nick
prognostiziert und bock kriege zwischen
herrn flickinger und herrn glück müssen
uns weiter entwickeln das ist alles
nicht so next generation
ich bin auf jeden fall sehr gespannt bin
ein großer fan von harald glööckler
tatsächlich hoffe nur da bleibt alles an
ort und stelle und verrutscht nicht
durch die hitze könnte das passiert ich
glaube es könnte was explodieren bei ihm
könnte es könnte ist wer ist denn ihr
persönlicher ganz persönlicher
top-favorit wer wird das ding nach hause
fahren wer wird die dschungelkrone
mitnehmen also ich habe einen favoriten
dass es jemand mit einer seriösen
künstlerischen ausbildung den ich als
ebenbürtig betrachtet dass es eric steht
fest er war hat eine umfassende
ausbildung genossen als sänger als
tänzer er hat ja auch schon mal dancing
on ice gewonnen er kennt seine mitte er
weiß seine mittel zu jonglieren aber es
gibt einen kleinen schwachpunkt er muss
zum killer werden wir wollen sie wie er
die anderen bei lebendigem leibe frist
und wenn man das noch beherrscht mit dem
wasser im gepäck hat er die besten
chancen dessen attraktiver malen er hat
spirit er hat bei base und künstler und
1 möchte ich abschließend noch sagen
viele teilnehmer überschätzen sich und
unterschätzen die mitstreiter und das
ist das beste rezept um zu scheitern
und wer eine so solide ausbildung
genossen hat wie herr steffel der
überschätzt sich nicht und unterschätzt
sich die konkurrenz deshalb glaube ich
hat er brillante chance also frauen
nicht gesagt eric steht fest wird es
gewinnen mein war wo meine prognose ist
harald glööckler wenn er nicht zu
weinerlich ist hmm und wird sehen uns
beim finale ich bin selber nennt sie
gewinnen kriegen sie wird von mir eine
flasche schampus wie wir gemeinsam
trinkerei grögler weiß warum er
eingeladen worden ist kinos ist
sozusagen und er wird das erfüllen und
das ist schon mal viel wert denn manche
sind ja da hingefahren um urlaub zu
machen ja urlaub machen wir hier nicht
bei uns geht es jetzt weiter mit den
wichtigsten nachrichten des tages
schalten sie am montag wieder einen da
geht es weiter mit dem bild forschung
fielen dann tonic und jetzt zurück zogaj
und patricia
einer etwas nicht so ganz gemütliche
atmosphäre wie hier